thank you man this is max um from austin
texas
what's up max from texas down there and
um
yeah elon musk said he might be moving
his plant down to texas
because he has issues with the way that
they're governing um
the the lockdown here in in california
onward
and well i'm in a fan for about two
years now dude
oh thank you man uh thank you for the
support brother
that's nice of you man but um
i'm 15 years old and uh that's important
because man i'm getting a job
as a busboy actually and um
i know you and uh billy comporto were
bus boys at around my age so um
i don't know man i'm really anxious
about dude i'm uh
i'm doing it helping my mom during this
corporate time dude but uh
all right man just send me back some
advice uh gang [ __ ] love you man
gang bruh and i love you too brother and
i'm glad look i'm glad first and
foremost that you're taking on new
opportunity to help out your mother
you know mother's day really is it's a
it's a that mother's day just a reminder
let's just lighten the fuse
the rest of the year is that candle baby
where we try to keep it burning for our
mother
and it's hard it's a hard relationship
sometimes but i love hearing this man
this makes me
feel this reminds me that i'm a son
and then i want to help out my mother as
well
and look i'll tell you man bus bullying
first of all
you have to remember that when you start
out as a bus boy
if if you start out like i started out
bees to the dub
baby balls to the wall son
you know what i'm saying nuts i mean
just
nuts to the freaking drywall
i mean i started out just i was i was
cruising
we had bread over there bro waters who
needs tea bro we had two different types
of tea that was the thing
and one of the pitchers had a little
orange slice on it a quarter orange
slice on
the tip of the pitcher and the other one
didn't
so if people got that tropical passion
tea
you had to get that orange slice picture
hit em with that one
and if they got that basic ast you know
you had to hit them with that regular
pitcher
and so we had that in water those were
the three pictures we had
so i'm running regular tees i'm running
passion teas
and then we had these kind of uh a very
light banana nut muffin
and these very light banana nut muffins
it was uh um you had to replace the tray
and then sometimes they had butter
sometimes you know big big lawrence or
somebody
big big uh big uh big bernadette roll in
there
and they throw six butters on a muffin
like damn
on a half a muffin they cut it in half
and stacked that [ __ ] up
with that monte kia that butter
so then we got to hit him with that
butter bam bam bam
but it was constantly just moving and
shaking bro yeah i had the apron i was
cruising
i had the rag stuffed in the corner
you know i had one wet rag and one
driveway one dry rag
so i was ready for anything
and i was smiling i was cruising i was
hyped i was excited but what i'm telling
you is this
if you start out at a new position as a
busboy you want to start out with some
enthusiasm
you want to uh but if you start out
balls to the wall they're always going
to expect balls to the wall
and what happened to me was over years
you know i ended up using steroids and
creatine
to enhance my performance
and uh because that was my sport man
in high school that was my sport man
being a busboy
and getting that minimum wage you know
pocket in that m dub baby
and so i was next thing you know i'm
using d-ball i'm using winstrom on test
200
test 240. some real questionable [ __ ]
that came out for a little while
but what i'm saying is if you start with
if you start at a level 10 they'll
always expect that level 10.
so if i could go back in time i'd have
started at a level 8
i'd have known i was capable of 10 and i
would have ramped it up around there
from about maybe
8 30 to 9 45 during the heat hours
or peak times they call it peak business
times that's when i would have ramped up
my ability
and then i would have ramped it down the
rest of the time
because i burnt out you know after at
two years i'm having to do
you know i'm on creatine i'm on you know
i'm on uppers bruh
i'm you know i'm meeting up with people
after work doing drug like i
i just got burned out because i but i
was a
dog i was alan iverson of [ __ ] dirty
tables
that's who i was and anybody in tucson
will tell you that
that knew about that in like early 2000s
um so that's all i would say man go in
there be passionate
and but have that extra gear you can
always go into
uh and if i could go back in time that's
how i would do it i'd have that extra
gear because i kind of ran out of it
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watches
one
ah